Heather maybe not with you but do you
know anyone who has any like crazy
paternity stories yes it's not even like
paternity stories I mean I know my dad's
my dad because we literally have the
exact same body shapes there's no way my
dad's dead but literally as I was like
putting him into the ground I was like
yeah yeah I'm his
um my mom though this is a very Boston
thing my mom's from Boston and her dad
was a big philanderer and she gets like
every two years we'll get a new sibling
on Facebook that will send her message
and say hey I think we're related and
then sure enough I mean in the last I'd
say 10 years she's had two new siblings
yeah it's crazy I'm going to tell you
this whole thing is crazy so rasan and
Heather have have either of you done the
23andMe thing have you actually done it
no I haven't and I gotta be honest with
you I was you know if I would have done
it four years ago when I was broke that
makes sense but I'm making a little coin
now and I'm way too afraid I don't want
anybody coming out of the woodwork being
like I'm related to you where's a check
well I haven't done it and I'll tell you
the reason why I haven't done it with
the government following you you know
what the government following no I I
don't either I'm kind of a little
conspiracy brother when it comes to
these [__] DNA people you know like I
think they're just gonna sell my [__]
DNA to somebody one day and I don't want
to do it so I did it you know pretty
early on I probably did it like five
years ago in fact I think they sent them
some to the office and a bunch of us
tried it or whatever and um there's no
doubt that my mother is my mother we
have the same teeth it's it's just it is
what it is but I got to tell you Rashad
when I was waiting for the results to
come back there's a tiny part of me that
was like what if my dad isn't my dad
then it turned out everything's fine but
for a minute I was like
oh man what if you know who like do I
want to know this and I guess some
people do that because they do want to
know it I just wanted to know if I was
Italian which I am [__] you that's kind
of what I was saying earlier in our
meeting is you know
I'm 38 I got two kids two young kids at
this point in my life both my parents
are together right so my dad's always
been in my life but if my mom came to me
at this point in my life was like hey
that's not really your father this other
man is your father I don't know if I
would have the energy to go establish
that relationship because I'm too
focused on my kids that's good and but
you just said it right too tired yeah
I'm honestly too exhausted to deal with
any of anything right now I'm dead
inside I'm really tired so yeah if
somebody were to come out and say no I'm
your real dad I'm like oh God do we have
to meet for lunch like what does that
look like you know you know what the
funny thing is Heather is that it seems
like all these websites like 23andMe
they were established so people could
trace their Roots right but what they
really turned into do I have siblings
out there that I don't know yeah no it's
Maury Povich I've been talking about
earlier it's just like you know you
aren't the father yeah I mean my mom and
the thing is too it's I know it's got to
be disappointing if you do find other
family members and then they like aren't
wealthy you know you're like at least
let me find like a rich brother a rich
sister that can you know send me a check
or something I remember we had I won't
say who it was but we had like a major
celebrity on our show years ago and it's
both this is so long ago it's before we
have TV and Howard was asking this
person you know they were adopted and
this person went to find their real
family and uh Howard goes um and was it
like one of those things where like they
were like white trash and there was a
trailer park and she goes absolutely not
Howard while she's shaking her head yes
she goes oh oh no Howard it wasn't like
that but that's what it is because you
know the odds are a lot of the time and
not all the time people have to give up
a kid because of finances and then some
of the time it's because of family shame
you know you get you get pregnant young
or whatever but um you know if you're
giving it up because of finances odds
are that those people might still be
broke and you might have you know you
might be better off but the dream is
you're going to find out that like oh I
have Steve Jobs kid